hi everybody  I'm going to be sharing today
about documenting things and how doing this with
intention can really help big organizations do
hard things around Tech and culture so I'm Julia
Lowndes. I am a marine ecologist and I grew up in
the r and open science communities and documenting
things has been a big big  part of my shift
towards uh doing my own research to supporting
other research teams doing research and so I
do that now through a program called Openscapes
and this is a huge collaborative effort with
many many people that I'm going to be sharing
from. so let's talk about documenting things
openly for future us so first of all  things
is all of the things uh this is your code
and Analysis icies your teaching resources
your onboarding and Community documentation your
fieldwork your lab notebooks events that you've
got your blog posts like you name it and future
us is really a mindset and a habit around the idea
that you're doing this work for our for yourself
for ourselves for our teams for our communities
and really thinking about that on different
time scales in the next hour in the next week
in the next decade so this is really getting
Beyond theide aidea of working by yourself on
your own laptop and really thinking about how
to be intentional and inclusive in the in the
work that you do so that others can benefit as
well  so documenting things does not have to
be painful that's one of the things I'd like to
share today  and in fact it's supposed to be
helpful it's supposed to be there for you so that
you're not having to repeat the same mistakes or
frustrations that you or others have had in the
past it does however take time and intention
it takes  support of yourself and others and it
really means kind of slowing down briefly in order
to speed up for yourself and others  over the
long term so really the purpose today is to help
you document things effectively and also hear
stories about how documentation can be can be
visible and valued and help teams be efficient
productive and less lonely so the structure of
this talk is going to be a five minute lightening
talk with practical tips and this is inspired by
Jenny Bryan naming files and Jenny Brian has
been such a role model and teacher about how
to document things well and share with others and
so I'm trying to bring some of that here and then
we'll have 10minute stories about repeatable
strategies from Community organizations at Nasa
and other places  so let's let's get started
documenting things have a place have an audience
in mind designed for readability and accessibility
have a place it doesn't matter where at first just
write it down write it down somewhere some kind
of software you're using get it get it on get it
have have a place there then having that place
will let you write as you go you'll be able to
develop a habit of writing things in that place
and one of the ways you'll do that is by copying
and pasting things you're already writing take it
from that slack message that email  this will
help you break down documentation that otherwise
can seem like a big looming task that might take
weeks to do  keyboard shortcuts are great for
cutting and pasting uh text from one place to
another you'll be able to write in a modular
way writing in small bits is less daunting
and it's easier to maintain collaboratively
you'll be able to write these little bits in a
way that can be networked so that you can link
back and forth to them because you don't need
a a linear flow when you're writing documentation
this will also help you  follow the concept of
don't repeat yourself which is something that
we can borrow from coding where you're trying
to have your code only written once that you
call by functions there's often also no true
order to what you're documenting and so you'll
be moving things around as you develop having
an audience in mind is key here  you're writing
this for someone that someone is probably you and
many others and different audiences at different
entry points so you can make your documentation
engaging it doesn't have to be dry or distant
writing in an inclusive tone is part of this
and having the mindset of we're in this together
and that your readers are intelligent people and
they're here and they're here to learn from you
so you can really consider your goals for your
documentation and the style that you want to have
that can welcome readers you can avoid specific
words that trivialize pretty complex things like
simply clone the repo like there's a lot to unpack
in a statement like that and thinking about how
to how to meet folks where they are there's a lot
of thoughtful resources that you can emulate and
these are just a few narrate code in small chunks
if you're presenting code so this is a you
can you can narrate uh your code in a way that
you would say it out loud if you were teaching it
and you can match that tone with your purpose
especially as you're trying to highlight
specific parts of your code for for Learners
to focus on uh we learned this morning that quto
has a new code annotation feature to help in this
in this as well sharing early is a big part about
writing documentation you want to be able to have
this be useful for for folks as soon as possible
and you want to be able to iterate it and receive
feedback and incorporate that feedback to improve
it this is where the idea of open comes in and
open does not need to mean public open can
mean shared with your team and you're
able to leverage different Technologies and the
permissions that come with them so that you can
share what you want broadly and also keep things
private I think about this as leaving breadcrumbs
for yourself and in this example this is a public
to documentation for NOA Fisheries where they're
still able to include internal links that are
just accessible to them but we're all able to
benefit from this documentation lastly design
for readability and accessibility and we're
able to leverage a lot of defaults on the on
the software side and best practices on the
community side in order to support these
goals using section headers is one one
thing we can do here these are important for
screen readers to help describe the section and
flow of a document and you're able to Anchor to
them directly so that you're able to share a URL
specifically anchored to a certain section of
your documentation naming things can be really
key here and you're able to embrace the idea
of the slug where the name of the header becomes
the URL so that you're able to give a little bit
more information about what that header is use
text formatting in your documentation this will
help you your readers follow along you're able
to hyperlink to the thing that is important for
people to look at rather than a word like here or
this that is it can be ambiguous and hard to see
as well you're also able to distinguish code with
fonts and use markdown in in this case as
well using alternative text for images is really
important this is something that describes
the details of the take-home messages of the
visuals so it's different from a caption in that
it will actually describe that a round Hedgehog
is knitting a yellow sock a rabbit with a teal
beanie is wearing one yellow one yellow sock
and it watches in anticipation and a shelf to the
left of them contains yarn in a tote labeled text
and knitting patterns in that tote are labeled
code so that is that concludes the lightning
talk about documenting things and I wanted now
shift to what's possible about this and tell a
few stories about our work with Openscapes um
so putting a focus on documentation has enabled
NASA to collaborate across divisions and support
users that are transitioning to Earth data Cloud
so as a reminder NASA collects an amazing amount
of data about our Earth they have many satellites
and missions that are collecting data that are
freely available for users who are studying our
planet who are studying climate change who
are studying Public Health agriculture sea
ice melt a lot of awesome and important work and
these data have been traditionally downloaded by
researchers in order to do analyses locally
and after many years of effort and planning
these data are being migrated to the cloud in AWS
West 2 and this means that researchers are going
to be taking their compute to the cloud in order
to analyze these data this means that this is a
a big shift in the way researchers have worked
their entire careers and it's also a shift for
the NASA staff who support researchers in terms
of how they teach users to access and work with
these data and this teaching this NASA NASA Earth
data cloud is going on by learning as a community
as we go so the NASA Openscapes project is a
uh project that I lead with my co-lead Aaron
Robinson and we are supporting a mentor group
across the NASA earth science data centers and
those folks are creating and teaching common
tutorials that that researchers are using
to migrate their analytical workflows to the cloud
so this is a huge effort around connecting folks
from different parts of an organization having
them be in a comfortable environment to learn
together to teach together to write documentation
together there's a lot of emphasis that we
put on building a psychologically safe space to
answer to ask questions to have a growth mindset
where we're able to learn and do together
what I'm not going to talk about today
is all of the amazing work that these folks are
doing to support researchers and instead I want
to focus on the documentation that makes it
possible so first of all we have a place
that researchers can go to to learn when to
Cloud how to think about uh using the cloud with
r and Python and other approaches so this is
the earth data Cloud cookbook it's made with
quto it's hosted on a GitHub reposit that we're
able to contribute to with Jupiter notebooks and
and our markdown documents and otherwise but
so this is the place that we started to have a
place to contribute to our audience was really
important we realized that it needed to be us
first and then specific researchers and so this
diagram shows that we really invested in our NASA
open Scapes Mentor community in order to write
documentation that would let us figure out how
to use the cloud and then we were able to then
support other staff across the NASA data centers
towards a specific workshop with researchers and
all the while contributing to the open science
Community through this documentation in terms of
design we're really emphasizing meeting people
where they are we don't assume experience with
GitHub with quto with cloud with python with r
with quto but we do have the expectation that
everyone can learn and teach these things and
so we're able to support folks coming from
where they are and point them to the skills
that they might need in order to contribute
or learn we're also able to collaborate on
this documentation across workflows because we're
using quto we're able to share these or combine um
Jupiter notebooks our Mark IR documents as well as
contribute in our kind of home places that we're
we're most happy working whether that's vs code
Jupiter R Studio mat lab or other otherwise one
other design element is that we're really reusing
and complementing existing work we found this
documentation system framework is a really
helpful way for us to write documentation it
helped us think about what was learning oriented
and writing those as longer form tutorials versus
what was problem oriented and could be quick um
how-to guides with copy and paced Tech or copy
and pasted code another part of complementing
existing work and learning from others has been
to be a part of the broader open science and
open source Community this has really helped
NASA mentors learn what's available scope how
what what the bounds of the contribution around
documentation should be as well as co-develop
and share and get that early feedback so what's
possible from all of this the amount of workshops
that the NASA mentors have led and supported
researchers who are now bringing their science to
the cloud and able to to leverage the capabilities
has been really amazing and again I'll point
you to the the place where many of these mentors
have been giving talks and supporting the
researchers which is awesome I want to take
it another level and talk about the documentation
and process and where we're taking it from here
so putting a focus on documentation has really
enabled this NASA Openscapes Community to grow
through intentional onboarding over the last three
years so the point that we're we're really trying
to build this sustainable Community within NASA
that's able to support user uh researchers in
the long term and have this documentation so that
folks can contribute so there's really been three
places for three different audiences that it's all
been designed for onboarding more NASA staff into
this Mentor community so that they're able to
support researchers the first place was that is
that we have a project website for NASA op Scapes
and the primary audience is really for leadership
and managers to have an idea of of all of the work
that the mentors are doing and really trying to
make some a lot of the invisible work more visible
we share all the slides and resources and
workshops in one place so that there's visibility
there and really in terms of an onboarding idea
there for onboarding mentors we're really
there to invite participation and have the in
that invitation and all the information that
goes along with it not live within a forwarded
email but actually have a place online that can be
updated if there if if necessary the second place
for onboarding mentors is actually in that Earth
data Cloud cookbook itself we have a contributing
section that was one of the earliest places
that we developed and that's really a welcome
for new mentors once they join this community
that's where they learn to how to access the
communication channels we have on GitHub and slack
and Jupiter Hub as well as all of the tech as
well as how to contribute and think about how
to do code review and pull requests and that kind
of thing and then we have another a third place
for onboarding and that's really in our opencape
team approach guide this is where we kind of
write documentation at this higher level for
ourselves where we're we're thinking about our
facilitation approaches the purpose of doing the
different things our timelines our checklists
and this has been the last thing that we have
had the bandwidth to document but we're we're um
dedicated to documenting this so it's possible
from all of this is that this Mentor Community is
growing and and taking more leadership of
the community because they're able to not only
repeat what we've done but iterate and and go
beyond and they're not having to start from
scratch about timelines or or onboarding texts
for emails and whatnot but beyond this what's neat
is that putting a focus on documentation has Ena
enabled no officies California waterboards and
other groups to see this and repeat this whole
process and this has been this has all been
just incredible ex and exciting work but what's
been neat is that the NASA Openscapes mentors
are part of this bigger cross-governmental group
that are teaching each other are learning about
what works and what doesn't work and and having
a shared place to collaborate so some of the
advice that we have as this broader Mentor
Community is to really invest in both Technical
and social infrastructure when you're thinking
about how to document things documenting things
will ultimately save time there'll be fewer emails
where people are emailing asking where things
are people will feel less stuck for uh well
they'll feel stuck for a shorter amount of times
hopefully and they'll they'll they'll really um
feel less lost and like they like they belong and
that's a really critical thing going like just
in general but specifically during this pandemic
and hybrid work culture so re this does though
require intention and time and this investment
in psychological safety and growth mindset is a
really is really important for documenting things
so we have yeah I'll I I'll I'll leave it there
but when you come back to thinking about
documenting things openly for future us it's
have a place have an audience in mind and designed
for repeatability and accessibility so thanks so
much thank you so much Julia so you mentioned
several times that there are different levels
of documentation right there are the technical
stuff there's the high level stuff and everything
in between the kind of recommendations you gave
for uh getting it done getting it on the ramp is
is this the same for all these kind of different
documentation types that's a good question for
the teaching resources that the NASA Openscapes
mentors are putting together that  we do that
that that process is a is a bit more intentional
well it's not a bit more intentional it is is
more intentional so it's done in a branch  we
have drive runs we review the materials we test
things in different places and and then that is
merged back into the cookbook  when we're
writing documentation on that higher level about
like the like when  like what what sort of
documentation or what sort of  Google doc we
should have in a one-on-one call for example
that might be something that we kind of push
to main pretty quickly and it I'm okay with
that being a little Messier  because it will
still help future us on our kind of Team level
so yeah there are different levels of like review
and and quality assurance absolutely is the short
answer fantastic so  as you said documentation
takes time and it is it is something that gives
back in a long time span can it be difficult
to kind of uh allow management and another
level to carve out the time where you don't feel
like you have to yourself prioritize it and uh
make space for it yeah yeah I think it I think
it's kind of a two a yes and approach  where
the idea of showing  what documentation can do
is important so if you if you take your messages
from slack and paste it into your quto book or
your Google doc if you can show that to folks
as being useful  that can help the second
step of advocating for more time to document
but having that like early thing to show that
like minimal viable product is is can be really
helpful but yeah I think advocating for this
is part of your time and part of your job is
like a big part of this fantastic thank you
so much Julia give her a round of [Applause]
applause